el ph se define como el menos logaritmo
en base 10 de la concentración de iones
de hidrógeno así que imaginemos que
tenemos que encontrar el ph del agua del
h2o y para encontrarlo lo que habrá que
tomar es el menos logaritmo esto es
igual al menos logaritmo en base 10 de
la concentración de iones de hidrógeno
del agua pero si el agua está a 25
grados celsius esta concentración es de
1.0 por 10 a la menos 7 molar entonces
habrá que tomarnos el menos logaritmo en
base 10 de esta cantidad y bueno si tú
sabes mucho de logaritmos esto lo puedes
hacer fácilmente en tu cabeza pero si no
sacamos nuestra calculadora que ya tengo
justo por aquí y entonces te mostraré
cómo hacerlo me voy a tomar 1.0 esto que
multiplica a 10 elevado a la potencia 7
negativo ok ya esto habrá que calcular
el lugar
el logaritmo esto me va a dar menos 7 y
después a esto habrá que tomarnos el
logaritmo negativo por lo tanto le voy a
cambiar el signo y nos va a dar 7 el
menos logaritmo de nuestro resultado por
lo tanto nuestra respuesta es 7 así que
si lo escribimos por acá voy a tener un
p h de 7
y si tú estás tomando dos cifras
significativas podemos poner 7.000 y
esto es porque nosotros ponemos dos
cifras significativas acá arriba una dos
es decir dos cifras significativas de
nuestra concentración y bueno esto es
porque cuando tú trabajas con logaritmos
las únicas cifras significativas son los
dígitos a la derecha del punto decimal
así que en este caso aquí tengo mi punto
decimal y entonces tengo una dos cifras
significativas relacionado a estos
números que tenemos aquí y entonces el
agua tiene un ph neutro entonces el agua
tiene un ph
ahora qué te parece si comparamos el ph
del agua con no sé el ph de otra
substancia se me ocurre tomarnos el ph
del jugo de naranja así que vamos a
intentar calcular el p h del jugo de
naranja e imagínate que nosotros sabemos
la concentración de iones de hidrógeno
del jugo de naranja y esta concentración
es de déjame escribirlo aquí a la
concentración de iones de hidrógeno de
jugo de naranja en este caso va a ser
igual a 1.5 por 10 a la menos 4 molar
perfecto entonces el p h del jugo de
naranja va a ser por lo que tenemos aquí
el menos logaritmo de la concentración
de iones de hidrógeno lo cual sabemos
que es esta cantidad 1.5 1.5 x
10 elevado a la menos 4 molar y ahora si
nosotros sacamos nuestra calculadora
para ver cuál es el resultado vamos a
hacerlo por aquí nosotros lo que
queremos calcular es 1.5 multiplicado
multiplicado por 10 elevado a la
potencia 4 negativo a la potencia menos
4 esto nos va a dar esta cantidad y
ahora a esto le vamos a calcular el
logaritmo perfecto y después habrá que
ponerle un signo negativo hambre hay que
cambiar el signo y nos va a dar 3.82
3.82 tomando dos cifras significativas
así que nuestro p h del jugo de naranja
nuestro p h del jugo de naranja va a ser
lo mismo que 3.82 y observa que acabó de
redondear la respuesta y además date
cuenta de que tenemos dos cifras
significativas después del punto decimal
y dos lo mismo pasaba acá arriba tengo
una y dos cifras significativas después
del punto decimal ahora este ph de 3.82
es menor que 7 y siempre que tengamos un
ph menor que 7 vamos a hablar de una
solución ácida cuando tenemos un p h
menor que 7 entonces vamos a decir que
es una solución ácida así
ahora qué tal si pensamos en el caso
contrario
imagínate que nos dan un ph y queremos
encontrar la concentración de iones de
hidrógeno y para hacerlo más sencillo me
voy a tomar este peaje
imagínate que nosotros tenemos un ph de
3.82 un ph de 3.82 y ahora lo que quiero
encontrar es la concentración de iones
de hidrógeno y bueno si nosotros
recordamos que el ph es exactamente lo
mismo que esto que tenemos aquí es lo
mismo que el menos logaritmo en base 10
de la concentración de iones de
hidrógeno entonces cómo puedo obtener
esa concentración h 3 o más ahora si lo
primero que hacemos es poner este signo
menos del otro lado me queda que menos
3.82 esto va a ser igual al logaritmo de
la concentración de iones de hidrógeno
de la concentración de iones de
hidrógeno
ahora resolviendo para la concentración
de iones de hidrógeno necesitamos tomar
el anti logaritmo estás de acuerdo el
anti logaritmo de menos 3.82 y esto es
lo mismo que 10 elevado a la menos 3.82
así que es hora de traer nuestra
calculadora y vamos a ver cuánto es 10
elevado a la potencia 3.82 negativa y
esto nos va a dar de respuesta 1.5 1.5
por 10 a la menos 4 si tomamos dos
cifras significativas después del punto
nos queda 1.5 por 10 a la menos 4 así
que vamos a escribirlo esto va a ser
igual
1.5 esto por 10 a la menos 4 y esa es la
concentración de los trillones de hidro
año lo cual bueno date cuenta que
tenemos dos cifras significativas aquí y
dos cifras significativas equipo y
además date cuenta de que esta respuesta
ya la sabíamos porque fue justo el
problema que resolvimos acá arriba
cierto así que llegamos a la respuesta
correcta y bueno de lo que quiero que te
des cuenta es que si necesitamos
encontrar la concentración de iones de
hidrógeno y vamos a escribirlo la
concentración de iones de hidrógeno está
la vamos a obtener común a bueno tomando
unos 10 elevado al menos
de lujo ya tenemos también cómo
encontrar la concentración de iones de
hidrógeno y de hecho ya encontramos el
ph del agua el ph del jugo de naranja
ahora vamos a trabajar con el ph del
amoniaco y para eso vamos a ver el
siguiente problema así que bajemos la
pantalla y vamos a trabajar ahora con
este problema que dicen calcular el p h
de una solución acuosa de amoniaco con
una concentración de iones de hidróxido
ojo de iones de hidróxido de 2.1 por 10
a la menos 3 molar ahora como lo que nos
piden es el ph y nosotros sabemos que el
p h es igual al menos logaritmo en base
10 de la concentración de iones de
hidrógeno de la concentración de iones
de hidrógeno
bueno pues date cuenta que no están
dando la concentración de iones de
hidróxido ahora cómo podemos trabajar
con ello necesitamos algo que nos
relacione la concentración
iones de hidrógeno de h3 o más con la
concentración de iones de hidróxido de
menos
h y bueno para eso vamos a trabajar con
una ecuación que vimos en el vídeo
anterior que decía que la concentración
de iones de hidrógeno de iones de
hidrógeno que multiplica a la
concentración de iones de hidróxido que
multiplica a esta concentración esto es
lo mismo que k w lo cual si recuerdas es
exactamente igual que 1.0 por 10 a la
menos 14 molar y bueno ya que tenemos
justo aquí esta nueva relación
entonces date cuenta que podemos
ingresar podemos sustituir estos datos
que nos dan justo aquí en la
concentración de iones de hidróxido y
entonces si ahora decimos que esta
concentración de iones de hidrógeno es x
entonces nos va a quedar que x que
multiplica a esta otra concentración que
sabemos cuánto vale
punto 1 por 10 a la menos 3 esto tiene
que ser igual acá w
que es 1.0 por 10 a la menos 14 o dicho
de otra manera si nosotros aquí
despejamos a x x va a ser igual y bueno
recuerda que que representa la
concentración de iones de hidrógeno que
es justo lo que nosotros queremos x va a
ser igual
am bueno la división de 1.0 por 10 en al
menos 14 entre 2.1 por 10 era menos 3 lo
cual lo podemos realizar con nuestra
calculadora me queda que justo por acá
1.0 por 10 a la menos 14 1.0 que
multiplica a 10 elevado a la 14 negativo
ok a esta cantidad la voy a dividir
entre
2.1 2.1 que multiplica a 10 elevado a la
3 negativo ok esto nos va a dar 4.76 a
4.8 ya que lo redondeamos por 10 a la
menos 12 recuerda que estamos tomando
dos cifras significativas y tenemos que
redondear 4.8 por 10 al menos 12 y lo
voy a escribir por acá esto me va a
quedar 4.8 por 10 a la menos 12 molar
muy bien y ahora date cuenta de lo
siguiente ya que tenemos esta
concentración de aquí bueno podemos
sustituir la justo por aquí y entonces
vamos a poder obtener el p h que es
justo lo que buscamos nuestro p h
nuestro p h va a ser exactamente igual
al menos logaritmo en base días de la
concentración de iones de tron ya que
sabemos que es 4.8
1.8 por 10 a la menos 12 molar muy bien
y ahora si nosotros sacamos nuestra
calculadora para ver cuántos esto de
aquí vamos a sacar nuestro p h entonces
vamos a decir que 4.8 4.8 que multiplica
a 10 elevado a la 12 negativo
esta cantidad de aquí yo le sacó el
logaritmo el logaritmo y después le
cambió el signo lo voy a poner positivo
entonces me va a dar
11.30 y 18 pero recuerda que como
buscamos dos cifras significativas hay
que redondear en este caso me va a
quedar
11.32 11.32 va a ser mi ph así que vamos
a escribirlo mi p h va a ser igual a
11.32 y date cuenta que ya tenemos dos
cifras significativas una que otra cam
y otra de lujo ahora mira en este caso
tenemos un ph un p h más grande que 7
mayor que 7 y en este caso que tengamos
un ph más grande que 7 entonces vamos a
hablar de una solución básica básica en
este caso tenemos una solución básica
así que nuestra solución de amoniaco va
a ser básica y bueno hay otra forma de
resolver este mismo problema pero para
eso vamos a hablar un poco del p
h recuerda el p h el p h es lo mismo que
el menos logaritmo en base 10 de la
concentración de iones de hidrógeno y
bueno eso también lo podríamos escribir
la siguiente manera el p h es lo mismo
que la en menos logaritmo de la
concentración de iones de hidrógeno
entonces si éste es nuestro ph ambas son
formas correctas de decir lo que va a
ser el p
h bueno pues el ph lo vamos a definir
como el menos logaritmo ok en base 10 de
la concentración de iones de hidróxido
de hidróxido así que empecemos por
calcular el ph del agua el p
h del agua y bueno recordando que si
tenemos agua a 25 grados celsius
entonces la concentración de iones de
hidróxido también es 1.0 por 10 a la
menos 7 así que el ph me va a quedar el
menos logaritmo de 1.0 por 10 a la menos
7 molar y bueno si te das cuenta es
exactamente lo mismo que 7 porque es
exactamente el mismo cálculo que hicimos
al sacar el ph del agua por lo tanto nos
va a quedar que el ph del agua es lo
mismo que 7 y una vez más fijándonos en
dos cifras indicativas tendríamos 7.00
perfecto así que el ph del agua era 7 y
el ph del agua también es 7 por lo tanto
podemos decir que el p h
el pp
h esto va a ser lo mismo que 77 que es
14 y esta es otra ecuación que tú puedes
usar para resolver tus problemas de
ácidos y bases
esta es una ecuación bastante importante
ok con esto vamos a resolver el problema
de nuevo calculando el ph del amoniaco
pero esta vez vamos a fijarnos en la
concentración de iones de hidróxido es
decir 2.1 por 10 a la menos 3 y esto lo
podemos sustituir justo aquí para
calcular el ph y entonces nos va a
quedar lo siguiente que el pp o h en
este problema va a ser exactamente lo
mismo que el menos logaritmo en base 10
de la concentración de iones de
hidróxido que es 2.1 por 10 a la menos 3
molar ok así que hagamos esto en nuestra
calculadora y nos va a quedar el peso h
esto nos va a quedar
2.1 que multiplican a 10
este elevado a la potencia 3 negativo ya
esto vamos a sacarle el logaritmo y
después le cambiamos el signo y me va a
quedar 2 puntos 67 7 y recuerda usando
dos cifras significativas y redondeando
me queda 2.68 así que escribamos lo el
peo h voy por acá el p
h en esta ocasión es exactamente lo
mismo a 2.68 y otra vez date cuenta que
tengo dos cifras significativas aquí
tengo dos cifras significativas ahora
bien ya que tenemos que el p
h es 2.68 ahora podemos sustituirlo en
nuestra nueva ecuación que tenemos aquí
para obtener el p
h así que vamos a sustituir este justo
aquí y me va a quedar lo siguiente que
el p h el p h más el ph que es 2.68 2.68
esto va a ser igual a 14 y bueno de aquí
voy a obtener que el p h esto es lo
mismo que 11.32 que es justo lo que
nosotros teníamos llegamos al mismo
resultado
11.32 entonces no importa qué camino
sigas vamos a obtener la misma respuesta
ahora voy a bajar la pantalla y voy a
moverle un poco porque quiero que veamos
la escala del ph esto que tenemos justo
aquí si recuerdas empezamos con el ph
del agua el cual tiene un ph de 7 y
estábamos justo a la mitad
tenemos un ph de 7 en este caso estamos
hablando del agua h
y decíamos que un ph de 7 es un ph
neutro
otro muy bien después estuvimos
platicando y trabajando con el ph del
jugo de naranjas recuerdas y obtuvimos
que el ph del jugo de naranja era 3
punto vamos a subir para recordarlo es
justo este de aquí tenemos un ph de 3.82
este aquí así que si nos regresamos por
acá y suponemos que por aquí tenemos el
3.82 entonces en este caso tenemos el ph
del jugo de naranja vamos a ponerlo aquí
del jugo de naranja muy bien y en este
caso teníamos un ph que era menor que 7
y entonces decíamos que teníamos una
solución ácida ácida recuerdas así que
cualquier cosa que tenga un ph menor que
7 va a ser una solución hacia
y después estuvimos platicando de el
amoniaco y su ph fue 11.32 esto que
tenemos aquí así que supongamos que por
aquí tengo el 11.32 y estoy hablando del
amoniaco
h 3 entonces en este caso tenemos un p h
el cual es más grande que 7 y bueno al
ser más grande que 7 hablábamos de una
solución básica de una solución básica
por lo tanto todo lo que está a la
derecha del agua en el ph son soluciones
básicas y bueno normalmente para tus
escalas de ph tenemos por aquí el 0 y
por aquí el 14 y casi todo cae en medio
del 0 y del 14 pero si es posible tener
por ejemplo un ph menor que cero cierto
todo depende de cuál sea la
concentración de idron eo y bueno todo
esto es la idea del ph todo comparado
con el agua pensando si una solución es
ácida o básica